et puis avec nos invités ici en plateau
Philippe Vigier bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes député démocrate
d'Eure-et-Loir Philippe Vigier qu'on
vous entendez aymeric Caron on a
l'impression que vous ne voulez pas voir
le problème en face que vous ne voulez
pas régler les causes en fait du
problème vous parlez des conséquences
moins des causes qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez lui dire
en m'exprimant j'ai dit quoi
premièrement que c'est un drame que ce
jeune soit mort 2 je faisais confiance à
la justice et pour moi la justice ça
fait partie du fonctionnement de la
République et d'ailleurs ces policiers
il est en prison ce policier
ce geste de Messi de volontaire donc on
verra on verra au bout il y a pourtant
une présomption d'innocence elle est
toujours là mais bref pour le moment on
en est là et on verra ce qui se passera
le moment venu et je dis à Aymeric Caron
je suis un peu plus ancien que lui comme
élu mais il est observateur dans son
rôle de journaliste
j'ai vécu les attentats 2015 vous voyez
ce qui s'est passé dans ces quartiers on
peut avoir des solutions différentes
entre nous dans le respect et dans le
débat mais moi je ne peux pas accepter
une seconde j'ai été maire pendant 16
ans
accepter une seconde qu'on casse une
bibliothèque qu'on casse un commissariat
que ça pour moi c'est totalement
intolérable parce qu'on rajoute de la
misère à la misère les mêmes vos amis
qui critiquent les services la
disparition des services publics sont
ceux qui de disent rien ils auraient dû
on va dire stop et voyez c'est très beau
message c'est cette grand-mère cette
grand-mère donc la grand-mère de ces
jeunes qui est décédé qui a dit il faut
arrêter c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire
moi j'attends c'est un débat projet
contre projet et c'est là où il y a des
difficultés pour le moment c'est le
moment de
j'allais dire pas que l'analyse d'abord
il faut que le calme revienne dans le
pays et ensuite ensuite chacun avec son
groupe politique chacun avec sa
sensibilité doit être en capacité de
faire des propulsions et je vois
d'ailleurs que au sein du groupe de la
nupette les communistes nous ont pas
suivi les socialistes n'ont pas suivi
madame Rousseau qui nous dit on peut
piller les magasins si on a faim non
mais attendez on est où quoi
encourager la violence avec vos propos
je vous ai écouté ben vous avez mal
écouté pardonnez-moi on peut comprendre
que s'il souffre il peut y avoir de la
violence
en tant que politique c'est de
comprendre ce qui se passe je comprends
les phénomènes je suis désolé
je condamne et moi j'ai bien j'ai bien
voulu vous écouter donc je vous en fait
une chose je vous en prie donc vos
propos voudriez dire en élu responsable
non la violence ne mène nulle part et ça
vous ne le dites pas parce que vous avez
manifestement un sujet avec cela
deuxièmement la police tue je suis
désolé la police nous protège et si
jamais il y a une bavure les policiers
seront condamnés moi je fais confiance
je fais confiance aux institutions de ce
pays d'ailleurs un d'entre vous monsieur
Boyard il est même protégé parce que lui
aussi il a eu des menaces de mort moi
j'ai eu deux trois fois des menaces de
mort donc ça n'est pas acceptable je
suis désolé deuxièmement vous dites ces
quartiers non quand on m'ignorera ne me
dit pas que la ruralité est abandonné
sinon vous viendrait chez moi vous
verrez tout ce qu'on a redéployé comme
service public en 20 ans et vous verrez
qu'on a apporté plus d'écoles plus de
médiathèques plus
périscolaire plus d'équipements je parle
des quartiers priorités
prioritaires vous vous avez bien cela
qui sont pardonnez-moi vous avez oublié
qu'il y a des petites villes moyennes
dans lesquelles des ouvrez pas du tout
mais là on est en train de parler vous
êtes en train de parler de ceux qui qui
cassent en ce moment mais oui que ceux
qui cassent mais vous vous parlez que
des cartes de sécurité et je vais vous
dire que on a mis 100 milliards dans les
quatre priorités il faut pas dire qu'on
études qu'on a rien fait la rénovation
insuffisant oui mais la réponse n'est
pas uniquement pécuniaire le problème de
la responsabilité des parents est un
sujet vous voulez pas l'aborder moi je
la mets à la fois l'aborder actuellement
dans un gamin n'a rien à faire avec des
tirs des mortiers dans l'espace
effectivement
Borlo ça doit vous parler quand même ce
plan il a été abandonné il a pas été mis
en œuvre comme il avait été présenté
alors le dernier plan là-dessus depuis
2005 les politiques de la ville c'est ce
qu'on a pu faire je rappelle qu'il y a
eu 30 ans de ministre d'ailleurs
socialiste de gauche de droite et on a
quand même réinvesti effectivement que
tu ne sois pas réussi évidemment qu'on
manque de structures intermédiaires
d'éducateurs de bien sûr encore mais il
y a une chose sur lesquelles on ne peut
pas et là on aura une différence
absolument majeure dès qu'il y a
violence vous devez dénoncer vous le
faites pas parce que quelque part vous
êtes bloqué sur ce sujet d'ailleurs je
vois que Mélenchon a changé il y a
quelques années il contestait le fait
que ces jeunes puissent commettre ses
actes là surtout pas un seul mot donc
franchement c'est l'apaisement doit
revenir
je suis à la tête
allez-y Philippe Vigier
au fort de l'ordre en général
une fois de plus je l'ai dit aymerican
si jamais il y a des policiers comme et
des exactions si jamais ils font des
actes qui étaient inacceptables si
jamais la justice doit passer elle doit
passer et elle passera vous la même
problème parce que a priori vous dites
déjà la police elle fonctionne pas elle
tue et systémique vous avez vous avez
parlé
je viens d'expliquer qu'il y avait des
policiers qui faisaient très bien leur
travail ça c'était un bout de votre
propos mais tout le reste de toute façon
on se souvient très bien comment
Monsieur Mélenchon lors d'une
perquisition c'est comporté avec
l'institution